DOUG: Good afternoon, everybody.
Is this on?
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
DOUG: OK.
Good afternoon.
And thank you for coming.
I'm very pleased to introduce
today Evan Thompson, author
and philosopher.
Dr. Thompson works in the
fields of cognitive science,
philosophy of mind, and Asian
and contemporary Buddhist
philosophy in dialogue with
Western philosophy and science.
He's a professor of the
philosophy department
at the University of British
Columbia in Vancouver,
and in 2013, was
elected a fellow
of the Royal Society of Canada.
As an undergraduate, he was
a student of Robert Thurman,
noted Buddhist scholar.
Dr. Thompson has been an
early participant in the Mind
and Life conferences
with the Dalai Lama,
where leading scientists,
scholars, and contemplatives
meet to collaborate
on research programs
to investigate the mind.
Dr. Thompson has authored
many articles and books,
including "The Embodied
Mind" and "Mind and Life."
His most recent work is
"Waking, Dreaming, Being,"
a thought-provoking book
centered around the questions
what is consciousness?
How does it relate to
the brain and body?
How does it relate
to our sense of self?
The book has been
widely praised.
It's been called a
groundbreaking exploration
of consciousness.
Dr. Richard Davidson,
researcher and founder
of the Center for
Healthy Minds, comments,
"It is a dazzling synthesis.
Thompson takes on some of the
most fundamental questions
about the nature of
mind, and addresses them
with remarkable
creativity and clarity.
This volume is a must-read for
any serious student of the mind
and consciousness."
And I can say I've read
it and I've enjoyed it.
There are many fascinating
things in the book.
So I recommend you read it, too.
And now I'll turn it over
to Professor Thompson
to guide us on a
stimulating journey
through "Waking,
Dreaming, and Being."
[APPLAUSE]
EVAN THOMPSON: Thank
you very much, Doug.
And also thanks to
[INAUDIBLE] for the invitation
to speak here.
And thanks to all of you
for coming to the talk.
What I would like to
do is to share with you
some of the main themes and
ideas of this book, "Waking,
Dreaming, Being."
And to give you the central
idea right at the outset, what
I explore in the
book is the idea
that the self is an
experiential process.
So the self is not a
thing or an entity.
It's a process.
And it's a process that's
under constant construction
and reconstruction.
And this happens in different
ways across waking and sleeping
and dreaming, lucid
dreaming, various kinds
of meditative states, focused
attention, open awareness,
and various altered
states of consciousness.
For example,
out-of-body experiences.
Now in the book,
what I do to discuss
these states of consciousness
in relation to the self
is to use a certain model that
comes from Indian philosophy.
And this is a model that we
see across different systems
of Indian
philosophical thinking.
Buddhist, but also Hindu, for
example in the [? Samkhya ?]
yoga tradition.
And its a model
that distinguishes
between awareness, the
sheer fact of awareness,
the various contents
of awareness
that change from moment to
moment, the thoughts we have,
the perceptions we have,
the dream images we have,
the memory images we have,
the emotions we have.
And then ways that we
identify with certain contents
of awareness as
I, or me, or mine,
versus others as not me,
or not I, or not mine.
So right now I'm in a
waking state, I believe.
And I have an experience of
body sensations and of thoughts.
And immediately
they are experienced
as mine versus the world,
which is experienced as not me.
So there's a basic
self/not self distinction
that's operative throughout the
changing contents of awareness.
And the Indian term for this,
the Sanskrit term for this, is
a [? ahumkara, ?] which
literally means I making.
The process of making a sense
of self, a sense of identity.
Or in a more cognitive
science language,
we would use the term
say self-identification.
Now with that model I
explore a whole range
of phenomena of consciousness.
In the waking
state-- perception,
attention, memory,
mind-wandering.
I'm going to say some
things about those today.
Different kinds of
meditative states.
States of focus single
pointed attention
versus a more open awareness.
Various experiences having
to do with dreaming,
which I'll also say
some things about today.
The experiences we
have just as we're
transitioning from waking into
dreaming or waking into sleep.
So sleep onset,
hypnagogic experiences,
those as distinct from
the dream state where
we have this experience of
being in a world in the dream
experience.
Lucid dreaming, where we come
to realize that we're dreaming.
And we can attend to our
state as a dream state,
or attend to the quality of
the experience as dreamlike.
Out-of-body experiences,
which can occur spontaneously,
or through partial
aspects of them
through virtual
reality technologies.
They are also one
feature of reported
near-death experiences.
So that's a whole other
family of experiences.
In the book I also
talk-- I won't
talk about this today unless
it comes up in questions.
I also talk about the
nature of dream, the sleep.
In many Indian
philosophical contexts,
contemplative context,
dreamless sleep
is not considered to be
just a blackout state.
It's considered to be a
state in which a certain kind
of subtle awareness
continues to be present,
and that you have a taste
of in the immediate moment
of awakening from a deep sleep.
And then I also talk
about the experience
of the dissolution
of consciousness,
or the breakdown of the self
in the process of dying.
And then the recent interest
in near-death experiences
in clinical and neuroscience
research contexts.
Now the approach that I take
is a neurophenomenological
approach.
This is a term that was
introduced by someone
I worked very closely with
for a number of years--
Francisco Varela, who is a
neuroscientist and a very
philosophical neuroscientist,
also a practicing Tibetan
Buddhist.
And he used the term
"neurophenomenology"
to refer to the idea
that phenomenology--
the study of experience,
what experience
is like from the perspective
of experience itself-- is
an important source of
insight and information
for neuroscience, or
for cognitive science,
more generally.
So there's a mutual circulation
between phenomenology--
the study of experience,
and neuroscience--
the study of the brain, and that
a particular really important
window onto that comes
through the kind of training
of the mind, training of
attention and awareness,
that we see in various kinds
of contemplative or meditative
practices.
So the idea that meditative
insight illuminates
phenomenology,
phenomenology provides us
an important source of
information for neuroscience.
Of course, there's the
neuroscientific study
of meditation, as well.
And that these things are all
in a mutually enlightening
and forming relationship.
And this is the
perspective that I
take in the book in discussing
all of these different kinds
of phenomena.
So I try to balance
the discussion
among these different methods
and sources of evidence.
OK.
So I'm going to go through
some basic points or themes
having to do with the experience
that we have through waking
and dreaming and lucid dreaming
in order to illustrate some
of these ideas.
So to begin with
the waking state,
the waking state is
one in which there
is an alternation,
an ongoing kind
of back and forth between what
cognitive psychologists would
call perceptual coupling--
that is, when we relate
to the outer world through
perception and action,
and our attention jumps from one
sensory stimulus to the other,
and we experience a sense of
self that's very much grounded
on the body and what the
body is doing in perception
and action-- versus
what would then
be perceptual decoupling, which
is the kind of relationship
that we have to inner thoughts
and mental contents that
spontaneously arise that
can grab our attention.
If we mind wander
or if we daydream,
or if we're
practicing meditation
where the perceptual
coupling aspect might be
say, attending to the breath.
But of course, if you engage
in a basic breath meditation
practice, you know
immediately that you move away
from the breath.
Some mental content arises.
It holds your attention.
And then at a certain point,
you notice that your attention
is held by that content.
You release it, let it go,
and return to the breath.
So that's a kind of cycle
of perceptual coupling,
and then awareness of
spontaneous mental content
returning to the perceptual
sensation of the breath.
Now until the waking state is
characterized by this dynamic.
Now I want to talk about a
study that I was involved in.
This is not talked about in the
book "Waking, Dreaming, Being,"
because it was just
published this year.
And this is a study that
looked at spontaneous thought
or spontaneous cognition and
the neural activity associated
with it studied
using fMRI imaging
in experienced
mindfulness practitioners.
So the participants
in the study were
18 long-term practitioners,
where that means over
estimated 3,000
hours of practice
in a particular
tradition of vipassana,
or insight meditation
tradition of Mahasi Sayadaw.
And the author, Sean
Pritchard, on this study,
is a clinical psychologist,
and was for many years
a monk in Asia, and
an experienced teacher
and practitioner of this
particular method of vipassana.
And so he was
involved in recruiting
the appropriate subjects who had
the experience for the study.
And the reasoning was basically
that in this style of practice,
one of the things that you do is
to notice when thoughts arise,
and to briefly label them-- body
sensation, emotion, narrative
thought-- and then to not
as it were kind of stick
to the thought, but to
note the thought, label it,
and then to let go.
So given that these
individuals engage
in this kind of
practice, the reasoning
was, well they
should actually be
quite good at noticing
when a thought first
arises in their
experience in a way that
would enable them to report it.
So the reasoning
was that they would
be very good at noticing the
arising of a thought in a way
that would enable
it to be reported,
and that this would then
provide a marker in time whereby
one could look at the
antecedent neural activity
to the reporting of the thought,
the neural activity when
the thought is being reported,
and the neural activity
subsequent to the thought,
and that that would provide
a way of looking at some
of the dynamics associated
with spontaneous cognition.
So in this study,
which was a study--
the first author
is Melissa Ellamil.
And the study was done in the
laboratory of Kalina Christoff
at the University
of British Columbia.
The procedure was to report
thoughts when they first
are noticed to have
arisen, and then
to indicate whether it's
an emotional thought,
or whether it's a visual
thought, or a narrative
thought, or a
thought having to do
with a sensation of the body.
And the control
in the experiment
was to then present according
to the same time course, words
that would be
perceptually recognized
as emotional or
visual or narrative.
And what they found is that
before the button press,
certain areas are
comparatively activated.
And these are memory
areas-- the hippocampus,
parahippocampus especially, and
the inferior parietal lobule--
that's before the button press.
During the button press,
another suite of areas
are comparatively activated.
And then after the button
press, another suite of areas
are activated.
So then the question is, what's
the interpretation of this?
I should say that
the idea here again,
is to get a kind of extended
picture of the dynamics
of brain activity
as thoughts arise,
compared to as words
are perceived that match
the kind of thought in content.
So this is what you see
for the thought arising,
but not for the word perception
in the comparative analysis.
And so the idea is
that, well, in the case
of spontaneous thought,
thoughts are born out
of memory, memory systems.
And they have a kind
of affective salience
that might have to do
with a body sensation,
or a kind of emotional content,
or a memory image or something
like that.
They capture attention.
So this is what the cognitive
scientists would talk about
as that moment where
there's a kind of decoupling
from the perception
because there's
a affect of salience
to the thought that's
capturing attention.
And then that can become a focus
for metacognition, that is,
for roughly thinking about the
thought, noticing the thought,
not sticking to it
if you're practicing
a kind of mindfulness meditation
where you note the thought,
but you don't get caught
up in the content.
And then whatever cognitive
and emotional aberration
ensues prior to
returning to, as it were,
releasing or
dropping the thought.
So memory reactivation then
is before the button press--
so memory areas of the brain.
The redirecting of the attention
to the recalled memory.
That's also before the
button press, presumably.
During the button
press, this is when
there's some kind of evaluation
or affective appraisal.
And then after the button
press, the metacognition
and the elaboration.
This is the kind of
model for interpreting
the neural findings.
So the point, then,
of the study is
to take advantage of
the particular skill
that this kind of meditation
practitioner has in a way
that illuminates something
about the dynamics of the waking
state, both
phenomenologically, but also
in terms of neural activations.
Now another study-- or this is
more of a theoretical piece,
a meta analysis with a
theoretical framing that
comes from the same lab
of Kalina Christoff,
with the first author
now Kieran Fox,
is to comparatively
analyze mind-wandering,
or spontaneous
cognition of the sort
that we were just looking at,
in relationship to dreaming.
So in this study they
compare neuroimaging results
from studies of
REM sleep dreaming
with neuroimaging results from
the study of mind-wandering.
And they compare the
first person reports,
the first person
content reports.
So it turns out there's
a lot of similarities.
That is, in both
cases, the content
is largely audiovisual and
emotional-- when you dream,
when you mind wander.
The structure is
loosely narrative.
And of course, its
tinged with various kinds
of fantasy elaboration.
The content on
analysis turns out
to be strongly related
to current concerns.
So you tend to mind
wander towards topics
that are of current
concern in your daily life.
And you tend to dream
in ways that reflect
current concerns as well.
That of course it draws
on long-term memory.
It simulates social
interactions.
So a lot of mind wandering
is imagining yourself,
or what would have
been better if I had
said this to my partner.
And that would've been a
much better thing to say.
Why did I say this?
We simulate and reenact
social situations.
And of course, that happens
a lot in dreams as well.
And we identify with now
not so much the bodily self,
but with a certain
mental image of the self.
So the mental image is
the content of awareness.
And we identify with
an image from memory
or an image in the
dream state as self.
In both cases,
meta-awareness-- so this
is awareness of the current
contents of consciousness,
or of the current state
of consciousness--
is comparatively lacking.
So often when you get caught
up in a daydream or mind
wandering, its only down the
road that you become aware of,
oh, my mind is wandering.
And of course, in a dream
that's a non-lucid dream,
you don't have awareness of
the state as a dream state.
That awareness is
actually what marks
the transition from a
dream into a lucid dream.
And I'll say more
about that in a minute.
And then from the
neuroscience perspective,
there's a large overlap
in activation patterns
of various cortical regions.
So both activate
regions involved
in self-referential
thought-- that
is thinking about something
in relationship to self
and evaluating it
in a certain way--
overlap of activations in
areas involving memory.
But in REM sleep, the
prefrontal cortical regions
that are crucial for aspects of
attention and cognitive control
are comparatively deactivated
beyond levels of deactivation
seen during waking
mind wandering,
and interestingly
in lucid dreaming,
they comparatively reactivate.
And I'll say more about that.
OK.
So that's by way of saying
we start with a waking state.
We look at the alternation
between perceptual modes
of experience, mind wandering,
spontaneous cognition.
That overlaps in certain ways
with features of dreaming.
So now what we want to do
is to really look at, well,
what marks dreaming as distinct
from that experientially
especially.
Also, of course, from the
perspective of the brain.
But starting with the
experiential differences.
And in order to
talk about this, I
want to differentiate between
the hypnogogic state--
so this is the state leading
into sleep, sleep onset--
dreaming, and lucid dreaming.
This is an image by a
painter, Pablo Roman Andrioli,
called "Hypnagogic Revelation."
And if you look at it,
it depicts the kind
of images that play
across your visual field
if you're falling into
sleep, and you're doing so
in a way where you're
not totally tired
and you just kind
of crash, as we say.
But you're actually kind
of drifting into sleep.
And you can become aware of
various kinds of visual images,
various sounds that
you're not sure
whether they're sort of in you
or whether they're in the room,
or thoughts that have
a peculiar quality.
They seem meaningful in a way.
But you can't quite
grasp what they are.
So these are all characteristics
of the hypnogogic state.
Hypnagogic literally just
means from the Greek,
leading into sleep.
One of my favorite descriptions
of the hypnagogic state
comes from Proust, from his
"Remembrance of Things Past."
The first volume, very
early in the book,
the unnamed narrator gives
the following description.
He says, "For a long
time I went to bed early.
Sometimes my candle
scarcely out,
my eyes would close so quickly
that I did not have time to say
to myself, 'I'm going to
sleep.' And half an hour later,
the thought that it was time
to try to sleep would wake me.
I wanted to put down the book I
thought I still had in my hands
and blow out my light.
I had not ceased while
sleeping to form reflections
on what I had just read.
But these reflections had
taken a rather peculiar turn.
It seemed to me
that I myself was
what the book was talking
about: a church, a quartet,
the rivalry between
Francois I and Charles IV."
So this is a description
that marks something
about the hypnagogic
state, which
is that there's a kind of to
use the psychoanalytic language,
there's a kind of dissolution
of ego boundaries.
The sense that the image is
one thing and I'm another.
That self/non-self
distinction breaks down.
And there's an absorption in the
image as if the image is you.
Or what you're thinking
about or what you were just
reading about is somehow you.
Or you're not separate from it.
And Proust really depicts this
quite marvelously, I think.
So there's a
dissolution as we fall
into sleep between the
boundaries of self and not self
as they're experientially
present in the waking state.
But there isn't the strong sense
of being immersed in a world.
So right now we
all have the sense
of the presence of the world.
We're immersed in a world.
We can move in certain ways.
We can perceive certain things.
And that reappears
in various ways
in the dream state, the sense
of being in the dream world.
But the hypnagogic
state is not like that.
There's not the sense
of being in a world.
There's this kind
of spectator quality
where you're sort
of watching things,
but they're not really
separate from you.
But you're sort of
fused into them.
So the consciousness has a kind
of spellbound or fascinated
quality.
These are actually
terms that Sarte
uses in his book
on the imagination
to talk about hypnagogia.
He says there's an
identification, a fascination,
with these images that
play spontaneously.
And they shift as
your eyes move.
And if you try to sort of
focus your attention on them
visually, they sort
of break apart.
You have to kind of let
them drift out of view.
And they're highly susceptible
to intention and suggestion.
Mm hm?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
EVAN THOMPSON: Well,
I would describe it
in the way I'm using the
term consciousness now
is still a conscious
state, because it's
an experiential state.
So when I use the
word "consciousness,"
I mean that there is the
experience of awareness.
There is some
content of awareness.
And there's some sense of self.
Or that sense of
self can drop out
in certain states
of consciousness.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
EVAN THOMPSON: So
you're in between.
So if you were to look at
it from the neuroscience
perspective, the
brain rhythms have
a certain characteristic
frequencies
as you move from waking into
relaxation into drowsiness
into falling asleep.
And we're in that drowsy
falling into sleep period.
But there's still an
awareness of the present,
and even sometimes an
awareness of the room.
So the awareness can still have
content from the environment
as well.
OK.
So the dream state then.
So that's sleep
onset, or hypnagogia.
The dream state.
This is Adam Elsheimer's
painting of "Jacob's Dream."
So Jacob's dream in the
Old Testament, genesis 28,
I think it is, Jacob dreams
of a ladder with the angels
going up and down from heaven.
And so one of the things
about the dream state
is the sense that
you're in a world,
and things are
happening in the world.
So that sense of
immersion with presence
where there's self
versus not-self
reappears in the
dream in a way where
it's dissolved in
the hypnagogic state.
The English poet Robert Herrick
has this wonderful little poem.
He says, "Here we
are all, by day;
by night, we're hurled
by dreams, each one
into a several world."
And this is an archaic use of
several, which means separate.
So we all seem to be sharing
a common world in waking.
As we go into our own dream
world, it's our world.
It's a separate world.
But he says, "we're hurled."
So there's the sense
of being immersed.
We're thrown into another world.
And that sense of immersion
is a particularly significant
feature of the dream state.
So in a hypnagogic state then,
we look at visual patterns.
And they absorb us.
But when we dream, we
experience being in the dream.
Or we experience being
in the dream world.
Here's another
wonderful description
of a dream experience
that I think many of us
have that's from a very
old work of literature.
Homer's "Iliad."
So this is when Hector has
gone outside of the city
walls of Troy to meet Achilles.
And Homer says, "As in a dream,
a man chasing another cannot
catch him.
Nor can he in flight
escape from his pursuer.
So Achilles could not by
his swiftness overtake him.
Nor could Hector pull away."
So this is a very
powerful image where
you may have had a dream in
which you're being chased.
This actually turns out to be
a common dream theme-- being
chased in a dream.
If you do content
analysis of dreams,
many people have
dreams like this.
So you're being chased.
And there's this
feeling that you
can't get away from the
one who's pursuing you.
But they're not
overtaking you either.
So Homer is using this
to depict the situation
of the battle that's
going to ensue
between Hector and Achilles.
Now if you think about
this description,
or what it might be like for
you to have a dream like that,
there's two ways in
which the dream might
be structured experientially.
On the one hand, you might
feel yourself in the dream.
So you're experiencing the dream
world through your own eyes.
And you're running.
And you're looking back
over your shoulder.
And you have this sense
that you're being pursued.
So that's a kind of first
person perspective in the dream.
But you may have had dreams
in which you see yourself
from the outside in the dream.
So there's an
image in the dream.
So in the case of a dream
where you're being chased,
you might first
experience it where
you're in the first
person perspective.
And you turn around.
But then it might shift.
And it's as if you're
sort of hovering
in the dream world looking
down and oh, I'm being chased.
And you see yourself
from the outside.
So this is the difference
between a third person
and a first person
perspective that
indicates the complexity of
self-experience in the dream.
The dream is nothing but a
content of one's awareness.
But in it, you mark a difference
between self and not-self.
But then that can complexify
where one aspect of self
is this observer.
And the other
aspect is the image
you see of yourself that
you say, oh, that's me.
Or you think, oh, that's me.
Now interestingly, exactly the
same thing happens in memory.
So if I were to ask you
to imagine your first
thought when you
woke up this morning.
And now I ask you what were
you wearing when you first
woke up this morning?
Now it may not have
been this way for you.
But when we ask
questions like that,
the memory tends to be biased.
And there's scientific
evidence supporting this.
So if I ask you what you were
thinking or how you felt,
the memory will tend to be in
the first person perspective.
And psychologists call
that a field memory.
It's as if you're
back in the bed.
And you're kind of reenacting
or reliving the situation.
But if I ask you something
factual, like what
were you wearing, or what
color were the sheets,
or how many pictures are on
the wall in your bedroom,
you might have the
outside perspective,
which psychologists
call observer memory.
It's as if you're sort
of hovering somewhere
in the scene.
And you see yourself in the bed.
And oh, you know, I was wearing
a white t-shirt, or whatever.
So the same thing happens in
dreams as happens in memory.
So there's a linkage then
between dreams and memory,
which is a very old idea, where
that structure of first person
inward experience versus
an outside perspective--
even though it's all
your own awareness--
happens in both cases.
So the sense of the self
in the dream state then,
in its fullest
description, would actually
require us also to say,
well, on the one hand there
is the self as dreamer.
That's you lying
asleep in the bed.
But then there's the
self as dreamed--
we could call that dream
ego-- in which you might
be experiencing it from
within, from the first person
perspective, or from an
outside observer perspective.
And I'm setting
it up in this way
because when we
come to lucid dream,
you will see that, of course,
this gets even more complex.
So lucid dreaming, then.
So this is another--
AUDIENCE: So you're
in the dream.
And self as a dream.
EVAN THOMPSON: Right.
So the person who's
dreaming is you in the bed.
But then there's whoever
you are in the dream
that you're having.
However you are in the
dream, that's the dream ego.
So.
AUDIENCE: So you are part of it.
EVAN THOMPSON: Exactly.
So in lucid dreams--
so this painting
is called "Dream Signs."
And I imagine many of you are
familiar with Stephen LaBerge's
work on lucid dreaming.
He's not the only one to
talk about this, of course.
Others do.
But one of the ideas is
that you might in a dream,
if you've trained yourself
to do this in waking life,
if something that
involves writing or a sign
appears in the dream,
you take note of it.
And then you look away.
And then you look back.
And very likely it's changed.
Whereas in the waking state,
you look at a stop sign.
You look away.
You look back.
It's a stop sign in the dream.
This is not sure fire.
But in a dream often, if you
look, and then look away,
and look back,
it'll be different.
And if you can notice
that difference,
then that can be a sign,
oh, I must be dreaming.
So it's one of the
kind of techniques
that's used to teach
yourself how to lucid dream.
OK.
So lucid dreaming.
So this is a topic that's
become increasingly popular.
And many people think,
well, lucid dreaming
means being able to
control the dream.
You have a dream.
And you can control it.
You know that you're dreaming.
And you can control the dream.
And that's not really how
I think of lucid dreaming
in a more precise sense.
For me, the mark
of a lucid dream
is not whether you
try to control it
or not, because some things are
going to stay out of control.
And you might not choose
to try to control anything.
The mark of a lucid dream is
you can direct your attention
to the experience as a dream.
That is to say, you can
direct your attention
to the dreamlike
quality of the state.
Now sometimes that might involve
having the full blown thought,
oh, I'm dreaming.
But other times,
not necessarily.
There's degrees of lucidity.
So you might have an
experience in which
there's a kind of feeling of
insight that this is dreamlike.
And the experience presents
in a dreamlike way.
And you attend to it in that
way without necessarily full
blown thinking, oh,
I'm having a dream.
So that it's important that
lucid dreaming isn't one thing.
But there's a whole
range of possibilities.
Or you might have an experience
in which you're lying in bed.
You know it's a dream.
You think it's a dream.
You remember other
lucid dreams you have.
You might decide to
try to experiment.
Or you might decide just
to sort of let it unfold.
There are all different
kinds of possibilities.
But typically, lucid
dreams involve features
like greater clarity
or vividness,
the subjective experience of
things being clearer or more
vivid, a kind of realism.
Things sometimes take on a hyper
real quality in a lucid dream.
There's a sense often of
emotional exhilaration
or a sense of freedom.
Often the realization
that it's a dream,
there's something
exhilarating about it
that's very hard to describe.
But if you've had the
sensation, then, of course,
you know what it's like.
So now the sense of self
in the lucid dream state
complexifies the discussion
that we've been having so far.
Because on the one hand,
there's the self as dreamer.
So you might in a full
blown lucid dream think,
I'm dreaming.
This is a dream.
So you know you're asleep.
And you have meta awareness
of the dream state.
So you're aware of the
state as a dream state.
The current contents of your
consciousness are dream images.
But then there is however
you are in the dream.
The dream ego.
The self as dream.
And maybe it's a flying dream.
And you think, I'm flying.
So of course, you're
not really flying.
Or let's not be too prejudicial
here with the word "really."
But the one who's
asleep in the bed
is not flying, because he
or she is asleep in the bed.
But the one in the
dream is flying.
So the pronoun "I" is picking
out two different aspects
of the total situation.
And you might even
have a situation
in which you know it's a dream.
And you know you're
asleep in the bed.
And you're observing
some situation
from the outside in which some
aspect of what your image is,
you identify as you.
OK.
So just to give you a
little bit of a taste
of some of the
neuroscience involved here.
This is a study that was done
by Ursula Voss couple years ago,
in which she used EEG to compare
the waking state with lucid REM
sleep and non-lucid REM sleep.
And basically what you see
in the higher frequencies
as recorded at the electrodes--
the higher frequencies,
say 32 to 48, the beta
and gamma frequencies,
fast oscillations-- is that the
lucid REM sleep and the waking
are more closely related
than the lucid REM
sleep is to the REM sleep.
And also the measure
of the coherence.
So actually these traces
are individual subjects.
And this is actually measuring
cross spectral density
coherence, which is a
measure of the synchrony
of the oscillatory activity.
So the point of
this is basically
that the lucid REM state
is a distinct state that
has some of the
features of REM sleep
and some of the features
of the waking state.
And it's marked as lucid,
because the individuals are
signaling using eye
movements that they're
aware of having a dream.
So in REM sleep,
your eyes dart about.
Otherwise, you can't move.
And it was discovered that
if you ask participants
when they become
aware of dreaming
to move their eyes in the
dream, to move the dream
ego eyes left, right, left,
right, that this correlates
with physical eye movements.
So you can actually mark off
epochs in which the person is
in a lucid REM sleep period.
Mm hm.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE] the
frequency of what [INAUDIBLE]?
EVAN THOMPSON: So these are
measures of electrical signals
at the scalp.
And the fast frequency in
the range of 32 to 48 cycles
a second, or hertz, which
drops off in REM sleep,
is still predominant
in lucid REM in a way
comparable to the waking state.
AUDIENCE: So it's
just like [INAUDIBLE].
EVAN THOMPSON: From
electrodes measuring
underlying cortical firings.
AUDIENCE: Oh.
OK.
EVAN THOMPSON: Yeah.
This is another
study that used fMRI.
This is from Martin
Dresler's lab in Germany.
And here so whereas
the EEG gives you
very good profile of the
temporal aspects of the brain
activity, it's not so good
for the spatial resolution.
So the fMRI gives a
better spatial picture.
And so there at the top you
see left, right, left, right.
Those are the eye
movements that mark off
the lucid dreaming epoch.
And from the fMRI
perspective, you
see comparatively
increased activity
in the dorsolateral
prefrontal cortex.
So this is one of
the areas involved
in executive cognitive control
and planning, and volition,
and cognitive control of
the attentional functions.
And then you also see
increased activity
in a bunch of neural
neocortical regions
that make up what's described
as a frontoparietal control
system.
So this integrates attentional
processing and memory,
and is involved also in
meta-awareness and state
awareness.
So you see these
comparatively re-activated
in the lucid dreaming as
compared to-- in the lucid REM
sleep as compared to the
non-lucid REM sleep in a way
that resembles more
of the waking state.
Back to the idea of self-making
or self-identification.
So now we have a
range of phenomena
that we can look at under the
heading of those concepts.
We have memory with the
field versus observer views.
We have mental time travel.
So you journey to
the past in memory.
You project yourself
forward into the future
in prospection or anticipation.
That involves a
mental image of self.
You can envision yourself
from within or from
without in either
memory or prospection.
There is dreaming
and lucid dreaming
with different self-experiences
and perspectives that
are involved there.
There's imagination.
If you just visualize
now the Eiffel Tower,
you would visualize
it presumably
from a certain perspective
that would involve
your body being positioned
in relationship to it
in a certain way.
You can do that from a
first person perspective,
or again, a third
person perspective.
There are out-of-body
experiences, which
I haven't really talked about.
But out-of-body
experiences are ones
in which you have a
dissociation or an alteration
in the normal experience
of embodiment,
because usually I experience
myself as where my body is,
and my agency as
where my body is.
But in an out-of-body
experience--
say spontaneously
happening in sleep--
I might have a vestibular
gravity experience of myself
up near the ceiling floating.
And then I see a visual image
of myself down in the bed.
So it presents not as
imagination, but as perceptual.
But it involves, again, an
outside perspective on oneself
through the visual image
of one's body separated
from the vestibular sense that
you have some location, say up
by the ceiling.
So self-experience can be
altered in that way as well.
Now interestingly from a
developmental perspective,
memory with the field and
observer perspectives,
imagination, daydreaming,
narrative self-dreaming,
these all appear to
developmentally emerge
as a suite together
around the age of five.
At least according to
David Foulkes' book,
though, this is an ongoing
area of research and debate.
And the developmental
perspective
is important for a
point that I want
to make about the importance
of social cognition
in structuring all of these
forms of self-experience.
So this is a
painting, El Greco's
"An Allegory," in which the
monkey, the boy, and the man
are all looking
at the same thing.
And that is, the boy
is lighting an ember.
They all know they're
looking at the same thing.
They're all aware of each other
So this is a case of
what psychologists
call joint attention.
Where you attend
to the same thing.
And I know that you're
attending to the same thing,
because I can follow
your eye gaze.
And you can follow mine.
And this emerges
developmentally in the course
of normal development.
Obviously, there are
differences with various kinds
of different developmental
disorders and so on.
And this is crucial
for social cognition.
Now one of the
interesting things
about this developmentally
is that at a certain point,
the infant experiences the
caregiver or the mother
or the father as paying
attention not say, just
to a toy that the infant's
also paying attention to,
but paying attention
to the infant herself.
So at a certain
point in development,
you understand that
you are the object
of the attention of the other.
And in order to understand this,
you have to in a certain way
understand the
possibility of there
being an outside
perspective on you,
that your experience
from within, as it were,
isn't the only way that you
can experience yourself--
you can experience
yourself by way
of understanding that
someone else sees you
from another perspective.
And of course, this is
crucial for social cognition,
and especially for things
like empathy and sympathy.
Now here's a description from
Michael Tomasello's book,
"The Cultural Origins
of Cognition,"
where he says, "as the child
begins to monitor adults
attention to outside entities,
that outside entity sometimes
turns out to be
the child herself.
And so she begins to monitor
adults attention to her,
and thus to see herself
from the outside.
She also comprehends
the role of the adult
from this same
outside vantage point.
And so overall, it
is as if she were
viewing the whole
scene from above,
with herself as just
one player in it."
So that's exactly what
you do in a way in memory.
You see yourself in
the observer memory.
You see yourself
from the outside
as if you're just one player
in the scene, or in the world.
And this developmentally is
linked to joint attention
and social cognition.
Think of it also in
terms of language.
The voice that we all seem to--
or many of us, at any rate--
carry around inside
our heads, where
we have this constant inner
stream of speech where
sometimes we seem to be
talking to who exactly?
To me.
But I'm the one who's talking.
So what exactly is going on?
Well, Vygotsky talked about
this in terms of the idea.
His theory was that in
development, higher cognitive
processes happen twice.
First socially.
And then they're internalized.
So you hear the
speech of others.
And then you internalize it.
And it becomes a kind
of inner narrative
that structures your
own sense of self,
especially the narrative
self, the sense
that the self has a history.
There's a story that
you came from somewhere.
That you're going to
some particular place.
So that aspect of self is
a social and linguistic
construction.
So then the question as we
go through all of this--
and I'm coming towards the end
now-- is well, is there a self?
Is there really a self?
What I've been saying is
that the self is a process.
It's an experiential process.
It's under constant
construction.
And I've just tried
to indicate some
of the ways it changes
across waking and sleeping
and mind wandering and
daydreaming and dreaming
and lucid dreaming.
Meditative states I just said
a little bit about in terms
of the practice of
mindfulness of thoughts
that we took advantage
of in the imaging study.
Various altered states
of consciousness
that I haven't
really talked about
too much, like
out-of-body experiences
or near-death experiences.
So it's a process
that's constantly being
configured and reconfigured.
So then well, what
exactly is it?
Is there really a self?
Well, one way to go
is that-- and this
is very popular
nowadays-- is what I call
a kind of neuroreductionist.
I actually call it
neuroneolism in my book.
And this is the idea that
well, really there is no self.
And sometimes this is
linked to Buddhism,
because in the Indian context,
the Buddha's idea was anatta
or anatman-- no self.
And so the idea is often
well, there really is no self.
And neuroscience is
saying the same thing
that the Buddha said.
All there really is-- this is
not the Buddha's words now.
This is the modern
neuroscience way of talking.
All there really is, is
the illusion of a self
created by the brain.
Now there's a sense
in which I think
that view gets something right.
But I also think it's misguided.
So the sense in which
it gets something right
is if you think the self
is a thing or an entity,
that it's single, that it's
unified, that it's permanent,
that to use
philosophical language,
it's a kind of a
substance, an entity.
If you think that the only
way there could be a self
is if it were like
that, well, then,
if there isn't anything
like that that you can find,
then it's going to follow
that there is no self.
But that's not really
the way we should
have been thinking about
the self in the first place.
Rather, as I've been
trying to illustrate,
the self is not a
thing or an entity.
It's a process.
And it's enacted.
That is to say, it's through
perception, through memory,
through social cognition,
through culture,
through language,
and through all
of that being rooted in
the life of the body, which
of course includes the brain,
but isn't just about the brain.
It's also about the
brain being in a body
geared into a world,
immersed in an environment.
That the self is
constantly being
enacted through that dynamics.
And so it's not a
fixed single thing.
And even if we
feel experientially
as if it is, of course, when we
examine it carefully, it's not.
It's a process.
So the way that I put this--
and I'm almost done here now.
The way that I put this in the
book is to say that "when I say
that the self is not a
thing, but a process,
what I mean is that it's a
process of 'I-ing,' a process
that enacts an 'I', and in which
the 'I' is no different from
the I-ing process itself,
rather like the way dancing is
a process that enacts the
dance in which the dance is no
different from the dancing."
So in summary then, or
in conclusion summary,
self-making-- this is the
Indian concept of ahamkara--
is like dancing.
And the self is like a dance,
not a thing or an entity,
but a process.
I'll stop there.
And hopefully we have some
time left for questions.
[APPLAUSE]
AUDIENCE: OK.
So I have to preface
this with a funny story.
I started reading your book
two or three weeks ago.
And I kept telling my wife, oh,
this is such profound stuff.
I wish I could as
this guy a question.
And you show up at Google.
So.
EVAN THOMPSON: Go for it.
AUDIENCE: Google is also--
[INTERPOSING VOICES]
AUDIENCE: Like a dream.
So the last chapter
in your book is
like, super-- it's on of the
most profound things I've read.
The whole thing, knowing
where you sum it all up.
I had this kind of
like intuitive flash
to reading David
Bohm and his concept
of implicate and
explicate order.
Is that an analogous
thing that occurred to you
when you were doing your thing?
EVAN THOMPSON: Yeah.
That's an interesting link.
So I'm not a physicist,
so I can't appreciate
the technicalities
or the specificity
of his theory of the implicate
explicate order in the physics
context.
AUDIENCE: I'm not one either.
It's just-- it seemed very
analogous [INAUDIBLE].
EVAN THOMPSON: Yeah,
I mean, I think
the similarity is the emphasis
on process and relationality,
rather than on substance.
That would be how
I would see it.
There's actually a
point in the book
where-- I met David
Bohm at one point
when I was just starting
as a-- actually,
I hadn't even started
as a graduate student.
I was at a conference.
And this neuroscientist
I mentioned,
Francisco Varela, who
is a family friend who
I worked with for many years.
I was at the
conference with my dad.
And Francisco Varela and David
Bohm were both presenting.
And I got to sort of sit at
the side while they had dinner.
And they had this long
argument about the mind.
And David Bohm thought
really neuroscience
wasn't the right way to
look at the mind at all.
He thought physics was
really the important thing.
And Varela thought, no, no.
Physics is fine.
But you're not really going
understand the mind unless you
have a biological perspective.
So they kind of-- I was just out
of being an undergrad student.
So I kind of watched
them play ping pong.
And it was great.
I mean, that's just in
a personal association.
But I mean I would say
now, knowing a bit more
about his thought, that it
would be the commonality
of the emphasis on process.
Yeah.
That's an interesting
connection.
AUDIENCE: So I
guess my question is
the specific on lucid dreaming.
So you showed the slide where
lucid dreaming is more matching
of more a waking state.
And so has there
been any studies
that show lucid
dreaming is-- does it
have that restoring aspect?
Because you know someone who's
dabbled in lucid dreaming.
I feel it just takes energy.
And when I do it, even though
I get a full night's sleep,
I am a little bit
dragging the next day.
So I mean, if you
come across anything
where lucid dreaming can also
help creativity, but also
you're losing out on that
restorative process of sleep.
EVAN THOMPSON: I
don't know if there's
been any real studies
in a clinical context
about the effects
of lucid dreaming
with regard to
restfulness or waking
cognitive function compared
to-- or lucid dreaming compared
to non-lucid dreaming.
I mean, I know that people
anecdotally often report
that well, the
lucid dream state is
very-- there's the kind of
excitation in the state.
And you know, your
alertness is ramped up.
And people have
sometimes said, so I
feel like I didn't have
as restful a sleep.
I think my own
sense-- again, I don't
think this is based
on evidence yet,
but this is my own
kind of sense--
is that it really
depends a lot on how
you approach lucid dreaming.
I think especially
if it's approached
in a contemplative
way, say in the context
of what in Tibetan Buddhism
would be called dream yoga,
or in the context of
Hindu yoga would be called
sleep yoga, where
it's an opportunity
to be aware of the mind
and the creative power
of the mind without
attachment, just
a kind of restful
observation, then my suspicion
would be that that would
have effects on how restful
or not it felt.
That's my own sense.
I'm not a really-- I can't
lucid dream on demand.
So I can't test it
myself experientially.
I mean, I lucid dream
reasonably frequently
with a certain amount of
ability to test certain things.
And my sense is that if
it's approached that way,
then I don't wake up in a
kind of excited, agitated way.
I wake up in a more balanced
way, I suppose you could say.
AUDIENCE: I'm curious if there's
many fMRI studies on either
those that are kind of
considered enlightened, where
they talk about the self
as no longer a process,
like maharishi.
You're familiar with that
where people that identify
with the capital S self.
Or there's also
psychotropic substances,
like salvia divinorum,
where people
report that they are no longer
at all identified with self.
And they are an object
in that experience.
And that being an
illegal substance,
I'm just curious if that's
now hitting the radar.
I know in "Search
Inside Yourself"
they did say some uses of
LSD were being brought back
into studies.
So just curious if one people
that sort of claim they
have this constant
awareness-- you know,
the Tibetans talk about
in "Waking, Dreaming,
Sleeping," there is a
very high level of state,
where you're just
constantly aware.
Has anybody like
that been studied?
And then second, are
they studying folks
under the influence of
drugs that can actually
sort of create that sense
for limited periods of time?
EVAN THOMPSON: Data on
those kinds of experiences
is very, very minimal
at this point.
I mean, LSD research is just
kind of getting going again.
Even the research on meditation
is very much still limited
by all sorts of things.
And there's always the
question of exactly how
to interpret reports like a
continuous constant awareness.
Certain traditions frame
things in terms of that.
So then there's the
likelihood that that
would be a report
that some individual
from a particular practice
tradition might make.
I myself stay away from
the enlightenment word.
I think it's not
helpful to think
of enlightenment as there's
a state that's enlightenment.
And we can study it in Brazilian
shamans and in Tibet meditators
and in secular Westerners.
I think enlightenment,
especially
from a history of religion,
history of philosophy
perspective, is a concept that's
used in different traditions
in different ways.
And it means different things.
And it's always in
some ways contested.
Different individuals make
claims for certain individuals
having attainments.
They function rhetorically
to legitimize in certain ways
in various communities.
So in that sense
I'm kind of-- it's
not that I don't think there
are states of profound awakening
and realization.
But kind of reifying them into
the category enlightenment,
I'm very wary of.
AUDIENCE: You mean like
non-dual awareness [INAUDIBLE].
EVAN THOMPSON: Mm hm.
But even there, like,
what exactly-- yeah.
What exactly does non-dual mean?
That's something
that if you look
at the history of
Buddhism, for example,
there's big disputes and debates
in Chinese Zen and Tibetan
Buddhism.
A lot rides on the debates
in terms of philosophy,
prestige, lineage.
So you know, I think
one of the dangers
of the scientific
research is thinking,
oh, there is this thing
non-dual awareness.
And now we're going to
image it in the scanner.
And I really think that that's
a kind of reification of a much
more complex phenomenon.
AUDIENCE: So you talked about
the sense of self as a process,
as enactment or construction
of consciousness.
I'm curious how
far you would you
take it in correlation
with some Buddhist thought?
I mean, one could say
everything is a construction.
Can we definitively say you
as a philosopher, a scientist,
that there exists
anything in itself
with a non-constructed
existence?
So how far do you take it?
EVAN THOMPSON: Yeah.
Well, I think
everything is processed.
And everything is under constant
construction as a process.
That would be the short answer.
I think not everything
involves the kind
of structured self-experience
that I've been talking about.
That's a particular way that
things can get constructed,
especially when we're
dealing with social cognition
and language.
That's very much
how we human beings
construct ourselves socially.
And it's an interesting
question how much
other forms of animal
life do things similarly
or differently.
But in terms of a broader kind
of metaphysical perspective
as a philosopher, I mean, I'm
very much of an orientation
that sees things as
a kind of process
all the way down, and under
constant construction,
or configuring and reconfiguring
all the way up and all
the way down.
AUDIENCE: We have
some questions online.
So in the interest
of time, I'll just
ask the one that
got the most vote.
So the question is,
what is the evidence
for a consistent
long-term meditation
practice enhancing and
improving the neural pathways
in the brain?
EVAN THOMPSON: I
would actually say,
to be quite frank, the evidence
right now is still very,
very-- I was going to say thin.
But that's kind of a
prejudicial way of putting it.
I think that we're not
in a situation where
we can say there is strong
evidence that the brain is
altered in ways that
are positive as a result
of meditation practice.
I think we have
reason to believe
that that might be the case.
But in terms of actual
evidence, the kinds
of studies with
the right controls,
I still think that that
evidence is not quite there yet,
despite all the hype
that it's there.
So I think scientific
honesty really
requires us saying that
could be something that
is borne out by future study.
And we may have good
reasons to hypothesize that.
But in terms of actual
evidence, that's
really not on the table yet.
The one other thing
I would say is
that we read a lot,
meditation changes the brain.
But everything changes
the brain all the time.
If I take a sip of
water from the bottle,
my brain is changed.
So the idea that there's
something special
about meditation
cause it changes
the brain, that's really hype.
Everything all the
time changes the brain.
And the question is, OK.
So how does it change the brain?
Under what conditions?
In what context?
And the danger is that we
focus just on the brain.
Because it's about community.
It's about culture.
It's about history.
And that is as much,
if not more, important
than just looking
at what the brain is
as we can currently measure it.
That's a long answer.
But that's my position.
AUDIENCE: So I just
want to hear you
speak to the concept of
neural diversity in continuum.
We have a lot of
conversations in society
now about autism,
Asperger's, things like that.
How does the sense of self
kind of intersect with that?
EVAN THOMPSON: I mean,
I think that's a really
huge and important question.
And I'm not by any means-- I
don't really have the expertise
to address it in a full way.
But I think that any account
of self-experience has to take
account of the various kinds
of different developmental
trajectories that appear
with autism or Asperger's.
And again, there
all I would want
to say is that we shouldn't
leap to think that it's all just
a matter of the brain
being different.
That again, a lot
of what happens
in culture and society and
social practices, I think,
is really important there.
And wider somatic perspectives
than just the brain.
But it's definitely an
aspect of self-experience
that would need to be part
of a more complete account.
It's not something I
talk about in my book.
I don't really have the
expertise to address it.
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: I've got a question.
After years of research and work
in this field, and by the way,
thank you for all your ideas.
How has that helped
you in your life?
Or did it help to make sense
of the world of your existence,
like, for you personally?
EVAN THOMPSON: I'm almost at a
loss as to know where to begin,
because in so many
different ways.
So I mean, I'm a
philosopher by training.
So what's very important
to me in thinking
about philosophical questions
of the meaning of life,
or what happens at
death, or how should
we as finite limited
creatures face something
like the inevitability
of death, that
the contemplative
perspectives on the one hand
bring a depth of mental
training and practice to that.
But having the scientific
perspective complement
that, where we can have the
scientific knowledge together
with the contemplative
knowledge inform-- I'll
just take death as an example,
because it's something
that I've been thinking a
fair amount about recently.
You know, we're a culture
that kind of hides
from and runs away from death.
So having the kind of rich,
contemplative perspective
informed by rich philosophies
with deep scientific knowledge,
I think really has
made a difference to me
in how I think about
how I would want
to die, how I want to live
given that I'm going to die,
what hospice care could
be like if we really
had that kind of sensibility.
So those are just
some of the things
that kind of come
out immediately
in response to your question.
AUDIENCE: You mentioned it
just now in death, and also
previously in your talk
around near-death experiences.
I was curious to hear
your kind of perspective
on near-death experiences,
and how it impacts your work.
EVAN THOMPSON: Yeah.
So I think near-death
experiences
are experiences that
have been reported,
or things we can call near-death
experiences have been reported
in many different cultures, many
different historical periods.
There's also ways
in which they're
unique and new because of
our medical resuscitation
techniques.
It's unquestionably the
case, it seems to me,
that these experiences are
genuine experiences that have
distinct phenomenal features.
At the same time, the
inferences that some people want
to make that they show that
consciousness transcends
the brain, I don't think
a careful examination
of the near-death experience
literature supports that.
It might some day.
I'm not saying that
it couldn't possibly.
But I don't think
it's the case now.
I think the most
important thing about them
is that they might tell
us something about what
people under certain conditions
experience when they're dying,
or when they perceive
themselves to be dying.
And that's very important
information for us
to have for what I was
just talking about,
for thinking about how we should
face an experience like that,
that we're all in some
way going to have.
Maybe that when we die, we don't
have a near-death experience
in that exact sense.
But the idea that
all of us are going
to suffer from cardiac
arrest eventually,
and that that's
something that we
want to be prepared
for experientially,
will those experiences
give us some information
to help us with that?
That's how I approach it.
DOUG: OK.
And I think we'll have
to wrap it up there.
So thank you again,
Professor Thompson.
It's been a most
illuminating hour.
EVAN THOMPSON: Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]